[Music]
so here i have two devices
and i will transfer one dollar from this
device to this device instantaneously
enter the amount
and send
i'm seeing the transaction now
[Music]
and there it is
what you've just witnessed is what looks
like a standard financial transaction
money was transferred electronically
from one account to another
but while it appears like an ordinary
bank transfer
it may perhaps be the most revolutionary
technology you're likely to see in your
lifetime
this technology is called bitcoin
money makes possible the exchange of
many different goods and services among
many different people
wherever we go we see money being used
as a medium of exchange
money is at the core of our existence
every day we transact with one another
currently almost all of our daily
transactions involve a third party
a bank credit card company or remittance
provider
and ultimately it's these institutions
that carry out the transaction on our
behalf
this is until the invention of bitcoin
bitcoin is truly one of the most
important inventions ever in the history
of humankind that's how big of an impact
it's going to have on our lives and it
sounds really difficult and complicated
and hard to understand hearing about it
if you'd only heard about email it would
sound difficult and complicated and hard
use bitcoin is literally easier to use
than email
[Music]
so what exactly is bitcoin
well for starters
bitcoin isn't actually a coin
bitcoin is a new form of money
a currency that lives solely on the
internet
one that some have even called magic
internet money
[Music]
i think part of the confusion is that
bitcoin is actually two different things
it's both a currency
and a payment network
and we've never had
one thing that's both of those at the
same time so the dollar is a currency
but it's not a payment network paypal
and visa are payment networks but
they're not currencies bitcoin is both
of those things at the same time but it
has this other property and that other
property is that it can instantly be
teleported
anywhere in the world just like that
almost for free and there's nothing that
anybody can do to block these
teleportations there's nothing anybody
can do to intercept these teleportations
and if you're careful about how you use
bitcoin you can do these teleportations
anonymously so with bitcoin with a push
of a button you can pay anyone anywhere
in the world or receive payment from
anyone anywhere in the world
[Music]
in the aftermath of the global financial
crisis an author using the pseudonym
satoshi nakamoto posted a nine-page
document onto an online forum
the document titled bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system
would soon become the building block for
what is today the first fully working
concept of decentralized money
these are the daily candles of bitcoin
just in the backdrop but i want to talk
about these are trend lines you've seen
them on other presentations even earlier
today
i started out working at bear stearns
back in 2007 so about a year and a half
or so before the financial crisis really
started to hit and after bear stearns i
joined jp morgan where i became a vp and
that was my last job all of these jobs
were either midtown or downtown
manhattan
tone vase is a wall street veteran
a former vp at jp morgan he now spends
his time studying and educating
audiences about bitcoin
bitcoin is generally difficult to
explain
uh you want to try and break it down as
simple as you can so the simplest way is
is basically it's a it's like a message
it's a digital message that you're
passing and normally we're all used to
computers we're all sending emails we're
all sending pictures but you're always
sending a copy anytime you hit the send
button in a computer
you always retain a copy you always
retain the original
and when it comes to financial
transactions you hit the send button and
you have an intermediary the bank that
is moving money from one account to
another
and this is the problem that bitcoin
solved it was able to take something
digital and when you hit the send button
you're not actually sending a copy
you're actually sending
um a digital object
at its core bitcoin is basically a new
monetary system
however bitcoin is unlike any other
system we've seen in the past because it
isn't centralized in one place
this decentralized nature of the bitcoin
platform is one of the things that make
it so unique and world-changing
[Music]
we're all familiar with paypal or visa
or bank of whatever
all of these traditional services that
we're used to
control who's allowed to have an account
who can send money from who from what
countries users can send money to other
countries users with bitcoin there is no
entity that's controlling any of that
there's just this software protocol that
anyone can write software to interact
with and then anyone can install that
software on their phone or on their
computer and once they have the software
installed
they can now interact with anyone else
anywhere in the entire world that's also
using the bitcoin software
this software that runs the bitcoin
protocol is commonly called a wallet a
digital purse which stores and allows
the holder to move bitcoins from one
wallet to another
the bitcoin protocol is open source
meaning that the programming code is
freely available to add to and
redistribute
in this way similar to anyone being able
to add a new website to the world wide
web programmers are able to add new
products to the bitcoin network
[Music]
we have jason for whom this is very late
evening because he's in australia uh and
we're about to do jason's first bitcoin
transaction over skype as our medium so
everyone can see how quick and easy it
is on my end i will hit
a send
and uh jason is going to hit request
so when he hits request a qr code should
have displayed in the middle of your
screen
and he's going to put it up to the
camera of skype so i can scan it with
the camera in my cell phone all right i
see the qr code
my phone is trying to scan it
and there it is i scanned it so i feel
kind of generous let's send jason
five dollars
so i have just sent
jason five dollars in bitcoin
uh and let me know when it's registering
on your end that you have five dollars
worth of bitcoin
and there it is
okay so that took about 10 to 15 seconds
[Music]
bitcoin enables users to send and
receive money instantly without the
involvement of a third party
this digital breakthrough allows the
user to effectively become their own
bank
this is a complex idea to handle but the
possibilities of this new bankless
currency are enormous
with the exception of actually handing
physical cash to you generally we have
to rely on third parties for lots of
different payments be it credit cards or
wire transfers internationally or even
sort of keeping cash under your bed
storing large amounts of cash we use
banks and what bitcoin does is allow us
to do all of those things without any
third parties so in that sense we can be
our own bank we can be our own payment
system we can be our own international
wire system we can be our own remittance
system we can do all of these things
without relying on any other third
parties that's what bitcoin allows us to
do
[Music]
before bitcoin all these companies like
paypal and decent bank of america and
you know any business they had a ledger
that kept track of all their account
balances so paypal has a ledger that
keeps track of exactly who has how much
money in each paypal account and that
ledger is stored on paypal servers and
paypal's data center somewhere
and before the invention of bitcoin
people thought that it was impossible
all the mathematicians and computer
scientists thought that it was
impossible to have consensus on a
distributed ledger like this but what
bitcoin did is it came along and figured
out how to keep track of the pledger
that keeps track of who has what
bitcoins but instead of that ledger
being on one data center it's on
everybody's computer across the entire
planet that's running the bitcoin
network including my laptop right here i
have a full copy of the entire bitcoin
uh ledger
[Music]
this public ledger known as the
blockchain
is perhaps what could make bitcoin a
financial game changer
bitcoin is what is known as a
cryptocurrency
meaning that it's a digital currency in
which encryption is used to regulate the
creation of new units and verify the
transfer of funds
new bitcoins come into existence through
a process called mining
a miner is a person or entity who runs a
very powerful computer in an effort to
solve a complex mathematical puzzle
known as a block
miners around the world compete to solve
or close a block and are rewarded with
newly generated bitcoins if they're
successful
all transactions that travel through the
bitcoin network are pieces of this
complex mathematical puzzle so when a
miner solves a puzzle they're actually
verifying the integrity of each and
every transaction
welcome
this is one
giant abandoned
recycling plant
we've got incinerators over there those
two big silos
right around this wall we have a
megawatt worth of solar panels
it's a lot um
that's about as much as what we consume
so we're going to be able to offset our
electrical costs completely
this is
a work in progress but a bitcoin mine is
a group of computers that contribute its
processing power to facilitating bitcoin
transfers and the security of the
network yeah it is one big supercomputer
and all these individual computers
are kind of throwing guesses at this
mathematical problem it's a it's a very
difficult problem it takes lots and lots
of computers to guess it
once that guess is
correct
that is sent to all the rest of the
computers and with that answer they
record
all the transactions that have been done
up to that point it's a very secure
system for
uh facilitating transfers recording
transfers and making sure that no kind
of
shady work has been done because there's
some methods in in financial
transactions where you could double
spend and this whole blockchain thing is
one great method of
making sure that doesn't happen
let's say if alice wants to send bob an
email
what would happen under the hood is that
along the path of the email across the
network
her email gets copied
in many places of the network
and eventually the final copy will be
relayed to bob
that's how email works that's how
digital transfers work and that's how it
should work for for the majority of
digital transfers
that's that's well and good however in
the case of money that would be
disastrous if if that were to be the way
that money was transferred digitally
you don't want copies of the same
dollar bill to be to exist on the
network that that would ruin the
scarcity uh uh premise of money
and so this was the problem that satoshi
nakamoto
tackled with the the creation of bitcoin
um and so what happens with bitcoin on
the bitcoin's blockchain is that when
alice wants to send one bitcoin to bob
she creates a transaction and that
transaction gets copied across the
entire network however this is different
than say a single email because that
transaction has embedded in it
instructions to the rest of the network
that says from here on out
control over this bitcoin is now
conferred to bob
okay and the rest of the network honors
that
one time i realized that wow bitcoin is
really difficult for people to
understand is i spent the whole evening
explaining bitcoin to a friend of mine
and then i got home that night and uh
she posted on my facebook page and she
goes yeah i was thinking more about
bitcoins and you were explaining bitcoin
mining and does that mean that bitcoins
are originally underground
i realized that
bitcoin's a difficult concept for for
people to understand and especially
bitcoin mining as well because bitcoins
are not originally underground
[Music]
for new users bitcoin can be a difficult
concept to understand
bitcoins aren't physical and they
certainly aren't underground
however there are some interesting
similarities between bitcoin and a
precious metal that is found underground
gold
gold has been money and a store of value
for thousands of years
today gold is mined all over the world
the amount of gold that can be extracted
from the ground decreases over the life
of a mine until eventually the miners
exhausted of all of its gold
bitcoins are also mined in a similar
fashion
the bitcoin algorithm is programmed so
that the reward for mining new bitcoins
is halved every four years until the
year 2140
when all bitcoins will have been deemed
to have been mined
perhaps the mysterious creator behind
bitcoin was trying to mimic the
attributes of gold almost as if to
create a digital gold coin which could
be divided and then sent instantly
around the world
i try to explain it in some really
simple way
like
miners bitcoin iron miners they receive
the reward
just because they maintain security of
bitcoin
mathematically it means that
you need to solve
quite difficult problems is that just
guessing process you have to make
millions and millions and millions of
guesses
and if you're right and you're able to
close all these transactions inside of
one block
you're successful and you receive 12.5
bitcoins as miner
originally this reward was 50 bitcoins
every four years
these
this reward for miners is two times
less so real world will be decreasing
over the time
the creator of bitcoin whoever he is
was a really really really smart guy
and uh he obviously liked math a lot
and he sat down and did some
calculations and thought to himself if
everybody in the entire world were to
start using bitcoin
how many bitcoins would we need in order
for that to be able to accommodate
everybody using bitcoin for this and uh
each bitcoin
can be divided down to a hundred
millionth of a bitcoin
and if everybody in the entire world
were to start using bitcoin as their
money the smallest unit of a bitcoin
which is called a satoshi it's 100
millionth of a bitcoin
would still be worth less than one u.s
penny if the entire world were to start
using bitcoin
so who is this satoshi nakamoto
two years after publishing the white
paper for the peer-to-peer electronic
cash system this mysterious figure
vanished never to be heard from again
the only clues to his or her identity
can be found in the white paper
some speculate he or she is of british
origin due to the writings containing
some british slang
others believe that rather than being
one person satoshi was a group of
hackers working in concert to create a
new monetary system which would
decentralize money as we know it
i think he was a clever guy he was not a
normal geek he had
good knowledge of the centralized
technology or
decentralization
he had good knowledge uh financial
system and he was
quite good coder
but the call the bitcoin is not
definitely the best one
so it's definitely possible to
to write better code there is also
conspiration theory if bitcoin code
was written by one guy or many different
guys hard to say
anyway i
especially
appreciate that it's
first fully working concept of the
centralized money
[Music]
it's very interesting like who satoshi
is
there's lots of speculation especially
among like the very early people in
bitcoin
but what difference does it make whether
we know who created bitcoin
uh
i don't i don't know that it makes any
difference there's lots of stuff that we
use that we don't know who created it
and yet it gives us a lot of advantages
in our day-to-day activities
i have no idea who satoshi is
we know very little about satoshi and so
he could be at an event he could be
someone we know he could be someone i've
spoken to he could be a friend of mine
for all i know i don't know who it is i
don't know if we'll ever know but it's a
fun game
am i satoshi
[Music]
i don't think i'll answer that one
regardless of the true identity of
satoshi what he or she has invented
could have profound effects on how our
world evolves into the future
because bitcoin enables the user to act
as their own bank in essence it frees
the user from the traditional
gatekeepers to their wealth
is
[Music]
we all use keys in our daily lives keys
allow us to access and control our
valued possessions they also protect our
valuables from being stolen
take your car as an example
holding the keys to your car allows you
access to it whenever you wish but
suppose you've had a few too many to
drink and your loyal friend confiscates
your keys from you the car may still be
yours but now you no longer control it
and must hail a ride home the same can
be said of our finances
although you may have the debit card and
password to your bank account the funds
aren't directly in your possession
every time you make a withdrawal or
transfer from your bank account the bank
is actually acting on your behalf and
moving the funds for you
this is where bitcoin is fundamentally
different
bitcoin enables an individual to hold
the private keys
of their own wealth so with pretty much
every asset that we have out there
we don't directly hold the dominion or
control over that asset
for example
the royal bank of scotland they had 700
000 accounts atms just
went down for the weekend nobody could
access the atms couldn't get money out
you have a credit card or a debit card
and it gets turned off because of
suspected fraud or you did a charge in a
unusual location well guess what the
credit card company holds those private
keys they get to make the choice not you
bitcoin is very very different in this
regard it is built on public private key
encryption
and what that means is that you send
bitcoins to the public key
and then in order to send the bitcoins
you have to be able to sign
with the private key
where the bitcoins uh currently reside
and that literally is a number that
private key is a number bitcoin nobody
gets to turn it off if you have the
private key you get to access it and use
it
with your bitcoin wallets there's
associated um what are called private
keys okay and these are literally what
they sound like they're private keys
that can open and unlock your
access to your funds but
let's be clear if you lose any of your
private keys you lose access to your
funds simple as that
[Music]
so we just bought some bitcoins out of a
local bitcoin atm and so what actually
comes out is what we call a cold wallet
it's a little piece of paper with two
squares on it or two things that look
like roche ink blotch tests and a bunch
of alphanumerics underneath each now the
top is the public key which is what
people would use to send bitcoins to
this address and the bottom one is the
private key
which is what you would use to scan in
order to retrieve bitcoins from this
address now it's very important to note
that that private key is something that
you really shouldn't be
showing around everywhere because
whoever scans this first will be able to
take the bitcoins off this address
also if you were to happen to lose this
piece of paper then you've actually
essentially lost your bitcoins because
nobody else has a copy of this private
key
right now there actually is some
bitcoins on this address so if you're
seeing this for the first time you may
be able to scan this off yourself and
take the bitcoins for yourself
[Music]
so here is a satori coin
there is a value of
0.001 bitcoin inside
in today's
exchange
rate
that would mean about 45 cents
so it's very minimal
amount but it is true bitcoin inside
now how to redeem the value out of this
token
one would have to peel off the hologram
sticker
in the back here we go
and then
our qr code would be exposed
and this qr code is the private key
information which is essentially like a
password
and with this
private key
and only with this private key
one can redeem
you can import
that value to your
bitcoin wallet
anything else physical has a very strong
sense of authority or authenticity
and to make the barrier to entry to
bitcoin as low as possible
i think everyone working on their
project felt it was really important
that someone could have
a part of bitcoin that they can hold in
their hands that's portable and
doesn't cost very much to get started
it's kind of a low commitment
object
because bitcoin is built on public
private key encryption the entire
workflow for sending payments
particularly online is fundamentally
different from that of credit cards
credit cards were never built to be used
on engine in the first place when the
credit cards were made there was no
internet
so a poll system is that you've given
the authorization to the merchant or the
credit card issue to pull from your bank
account
whenever it is that they feel that they
have the right to do so with a credit
card whenever you want to initiate a
transaction
you are effectively giving the keys to
the merchant right and you give your
keys to every merchant you you deal with
so every time you make a transaction for
example online or so you're taking a
risk because you're entrusting the
merchant with these this very personal
information which they could then take
to initiate transactions as well if they
wanted to
whereas bitcoin is a completely
different model where the control
is
more weighted towards the the consumer
the consumer then pushes their their
funds to you um and then
um if you're doing an internet service
right you could broadcast
a bitcoin address and anyone in the
world could send bitcoin to you if you
were a band a musical band
and you're you're performing on the
concert
and your concert was being broadcast
uh you know around the world if you put
up on the stage a a you know
a sign that had a bitcoin address
well you could be funded by anyone who's
watching that broadcast anytime they
watched it
from that point onward
my name is sanshiro fujimoto and i play
the saxophone and the other instruments
i compose and perform and make cds and i
make my living by
being a musician
today is a small live show i do
without no admission fee
and if you appreciate my music
then you can tip me
by tipping you don't know how much you
might get zero or if your performance is
great you might get more than you think
so
that makes me play better
[Music]
[Applause]
direct
interaction is more
more about the art itself and
if you tip
someone in the street you don't tip big
money you tip like
10 cents quarters and small money but
to send the small money on the internet
costs more than
what you supposed to tip so
bitcoin is much better way to tip
someone in the internet
bitcoin payments are a push system
meaning that the funds are pushed from
sender to receiver
this makes for a faster and cheaper
system than traditional pull systems
like credit card transactions
this in turn also means that bitcoin
transactions are final and cannot be
reversed
credit cards actually has about a six
month settlement time
even though the transaction looks like
it went through
the person can then call back and say
this was a fraudulent transaction
and then the credit card will take that
money away from the merchant in some
cases in some cases the credit card will
eat the cost and that's a chargeback now
we pay for this this is the three
percent fee merchants usually pay this
three percent in order to accept credit
cards so bitcoin transactions don't have
chargebacks i think of it as a good
thing
um as much as people like to say how how
great it is to dispute things
it very very rarely happens
almost never do you order something from
a legitimate company
and you were not satisfied and then the
company did not solve your problem
most of the time this situation happens
is when your credit card is actually
stolen
and your credit card is can always be
stolen everyone's credit card is all
over the internet is just luck
or bad luck if your credit card happens
to be used in a fraudulent transaction
we have some businesses accepting
bitcoin mostly restaurants for example
we have some restaurants here set up in
acapulco for merchants when they accept
bitcoin is for them to have another
option an innovative option and for them
they have they have a lot of advantages
we don't charge what the credit card
fees charge every time they slide the
the card three four five even ten
percent depending on the credit card we
don't charge anything we don't have a
minimum fee
you can pay
10 pesos 50 pesos we don't have a
minimum
with bitcoin payments lowering the cost
of doing business and eliminating the
possibility of fraudulent transactions
companies ranging from mom and pop
stores to multinational corporations
have started to embrace this new way to
transfer value
this is harvard medical school
and this is harvard here
i visit this here it's 1997-1999
the first large publicly traded company
to accept bitcoin is overstock
and they now ship goods to over 200
countries
last i checked amazon only ships to
about 50 60 countries so they're seeding
entire markets with entire populations
in the billions
uh not even fighting for that market
share
additionally if amazon accepted bitcoin
there would be no fraud there would be
no chargebacks so it would lower their
costs
it would greatly increase amazon's
profit margins to accept bitcoin
bitcoin allows merchants to accept
payments for their products and services
seamlessly and although it's becoming a
great tool for merchants to offer their
products to previously untapped markets
it's the people in these developing
countries who will benefit the most
[Music]
bitcoin is the easiest safest fastest
best option for people that don't have
bank accounts or that don't have ids or
they don't have anything but a
smartphone and there's lots and lots of
people in the world that that's the
position that they're in and bitcoin is
this fantastic solution and opportunity
for them to participate in the world's
economy without having to deal with
banks and having to jump through all
these hoops they just simply install an
app and now they're part of the world's
economy
something like
33 of the credit card transactions
coming out of africa are fraudulent so
nobody wants to take
business from africa it's just too risky
with bitcoin you know the funds are good
so as a merchant yeah pay with bitcoin
also anything you want you know that's
legal to africa
then they're able to start having
property rights
and property rights is really what's
going to help lift them up out of
poverty
[Music]
so bitcoin does get into the this niche
of the under service people in the
banking industry um so a lot of third
world countries they may not have access
to bank accounts they might not even
have ids to open a bank account
but if they have cell phones and if they
have access to the internet they can now
have the equivalent of a bank in their
cell phone
according to the latest world bank
figures there are approximately two
billion unbanked people throughout the
developing world
the adoption and use of bitcoin in these
countries could transform this human
rights issue and allow the unbanked
population of the world to participate
in the global economy
for the first time in the entire history
of the world
anyone can now send or receive any
amount of money with anyone else
anywhere
instantly basically for free and it's
impossible for anyone including
governments to stop them from doing that
and as much as i love gold
gold gold can't do that right
think about that
anybody in this room you can now sin and
receive any amount of money with anyone
anywhere in the world right now and
there's nothing that anybody can do to
stop that that was not possible before
the invention of bitcoin and that is a
fundamentally world-changing technology
for every single human being on the
planet
wikileaks was able to find funding
through bitcoin
and this was in the midst of a financial
blockade that wikileaks was facing at
the time the u.s had ordered the
visa
i think was mastercard as well bank of
america to blockade any donations to
wikileaks
say what you will about wiki you know
wikileaks
not necessarily that i condone
everything that they do but i do think
it is very important
for freedom in the world for people to
have
uncensorable ability to to donate money
to whatever political classes that they
want to and so i thought that was
extremely powerful
for
wikileaks to be able to defy the us in
that sense
because bitcoin puts the private keys of
wealth in the hands of the user it can
be used to support activist causes
but bitcoin can also be used for a night
out on the town
my name is ken shishido
i am co-organizer for
tokyo bitcoin meetup group
we have this special event tonight
having burlesque dancers receiving
bitcoin tips
the reason why i do this is that
sometimes we want to
make our meetup
interesting
instead of you know talking about really
really technical stuff or political
stuff so this is one of the events we
want to make it really
fun and see what can be done using
bitcoin
[Music]
currently
if you're living in in most countries
buying things is not a problem you have
credit cards you can still use cash
and to me
that is not the true use of bitcoin the
true use of bitcoin is to give you
financial privacy which i find extremely
important
during the global financial crisis
as cracks in the financial system spread
institutions once thought to be
invincible were shown to be vulnerable
as we now know governments around the
world were forced to bail out financial
institutions
a bailout is when government takes
taxpayer money and gives it to an
irresponsible financial institution to
bail out their mistakes
a bailin is different in that laws are
written which permit financial
institutions to take funds directly from
customer accounts to shore up their
losses
such a thing occurred in cyprus in 2013.
when i started learning about bitcoin
back in 2013 especially during the
cyprus event
when banks were shut down and money was
confiscated from people
i remember telling my co-workers some of
the phds the quants
this is really bad
this is actually going to probably start
happening in many other western
countries and they were all laughing at
me saying no it's just cyprus it'll
never happen here
and that's when i knew someone must have
come up with a way to get around this
problem
when a depositor deposits dollars or
euros into the bank
title to the dollars or euros transfers
to the bank and those depositors become
unsecured creditors of the bank if the
banks screw up for whatever reason
there's now been legislation passed in
many of the countries where they can be
bailed in
meaning that their deposits can be
turned into shares of the
bank jeff berwick is an entrepreneur
financial commentator and podcast host
having founded stockhouse.com canada's
largest financial news website jeff's
analysis writings and videos have been
viewed by millions of people around the
world
it's difficult to say exactly what's
going to happen in the future but it's
definitely going to keep happening i
said after cyprus is going to happen in
greece and then they shut down the banks
in greece for months uh and re of
interest to people who live in europe is
on january 1st of this year they passed
a european bank bail-in legislation
so that that should be a huge wake-up
call to people that they're doing that
so in cyprus they didn't actually pass
it before so in cyprus they closed the
banks then they came up with some
legislation and said the banks could
just take their customers money to keep
afloat
so they didn't even have that
legislation and they did that in cyprus
now they already have it in place so
they know what's coming
i see
bitcoin as a way to
protect and hide your assets
and we're not saying this is bad
i'm not saying that only criminals hide
their assets no
people that have worked hard and they've
paid taxes
and they've done everything
and like what happened in the greece and
cyprus where
money in bank accounts was just
confiscated so if the next time the
banking system gets in trouble
it could be users accounts that are
rated to help
fund the banking system
we're talking people
with significant money
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
but it's legal money they've worked hard
for it
some economists believe that the global
financial crisis of the last decade was
just a precursor to a much larger
calamity
if this is the case how will governments
react in response to the next failure of
our financial system
unlike the current banking system
bitcoin allows individuals to hold the
private keys to their wealth
however this also comes with the added
responsibility of securing the bitcoins
with bitcoin you're in 100 complete
control of your own money but that also
means you're
100 responsible for what happens to your
own money so it's your job to make sure
that you keep your bitcoin safe people
are used to things like credit cards and
bank accounts and paypal and if your
credit card gets stolen you just call
the credit card company and they cancel
it and that's the end of it if your
bitcoins get stolen there's nobody that
you can call to ask to for uh ask for
help
but uh the other side of the coin there
is there's nobody that you have to call
to ask for permission to use your
bitcoins however you want so it cuts
both ways
mount gox the tokyo-based bitcoin
exchange has filed for bankruptcy
protection the announcement comes days
after the exchange announced that as
much as 450 million dollars of the
virtual currency had gone missing
ceo mark capelli's apologize and bowed
deeply on japanese television
it remains unclear if the missing
bitcoins were stolen voided by
technological flaws or both
so actually this is the the old mount
gox building
mount gox was the biggest bitcoin
exchange that ever existed i think at
some point they were doing over 100
million dollars a day worth of volume
and
they collapsed in a quite a spectacular
fashion in
2014.
i think the size of the losses amounted
to over 450 million dollars
they claim to have lost
850 000 bitcoins of which 200 000 were
found afterwards in some old wallet
people were putting money in and
essentially giving them their bitcoins
giving them the control of the private
keys and and the irony is that exact
centralization risk
is what bitcoin is supposed to
free us from
and mount gox just took all of the
decentralized nature of bitcoin and put
it into one company with a lot of
people's money and then on top of that
put the control of that company's
finances under one person who has the
keys of the kingdom
so we've probably seen over the last two
or three years
i would by my account probably somewhere
between half a dozen um
to upwards of 10 different
major hacks of companies that are
involved in bitcoin
and one thing you have to understand is
that bitcoin is fundamentally different
from
securing an asset that's
you know that's held within the regular
financial space
uh with bitcoin if you ever get access
to the private key of tucson's wallet
you can initiate a transaction
outside of the infrastructure of that
company without their knowledge that's
unlike anything that exists currently in
the financial space where if you want to
take money out of the
uh you know that target you have to have
infiltrated their their infrastructure
i think it's part of the mentality where
people are trained not to trust
themselves with their own money and so
everybody puts their money in bank for
safekeeping and so that that sort of
mentality where you put your money in in
some pooled company whose sole purpose
is to safeguard it
that is a really hard stigma to break
the change um and i think this is the
thing that's the most challenging about
bitcoin is that
it challenges people to question that
stigma
it challenges people to take control of
your own
money and value and to safeguard it
yourself
as we know at this time bitcoin is quite
secure
if you have more than a half of bitcoin
natural power you can take a control of
the bitcoin network but technically
this is really hard when we consider the
current bitcoin
power
it's almost impossible
so from this point of view bitcoin is
much secure than the the biggest and
most secure portals of some biggest
banks in the world
the problem is that many people do not
trust bitcoin just
because there were a lot of news about
hacking some bitcoin portals and some
exchange
services and so on the problem is that
like
all services uh based on bitcoins is not
a bitcoin you know itself so you can you
cannot associate
or
you cannot associate the security of
bitcoin-based services with the bitcoin
itself
the collapse of the mount gogg's bitcoin
exchange in 2014 caused much confusion
and skepticism about the security of
bitcoin
however years after the collapse of the
one's largest bitcoin exchange bitcoin
is now on the radar of many institutions
within the financial industry
the big
question that the conversation you you
would you'd hear it
is that the question was whether
uh blockchain technology would impact
the financial industry
and now if you go to the trade shows and
you listen to
the media the question is not whether
the question is how blockchain
technology will
impact
and transform the financial industry
it's now a foregone conclusion that
blockchain technology will impact the
financial industry in a major way
so that's where we are now but we
weren't always there uh if you look just
three years ago two years ago um
the attitude was that bitcoin was
um almost a laughable concept and it was
a non-sustainable system and it couldn't
be applied in the financial space
in japan the virtual currency law has
passed in the lower house
and hopefully actually it will pass in
the upper house as well in the very near
future
that means actually government
recognizes the existence of the virtual
currency
and then trying to actually set some
regressions
and trying to actually support the
business
[Music]
this bitcoin
well it looks uh great you know
it's a
nice piece of collection you know
better than a
yen or a penny
some of the areas where bitcoin has been
most popular so far is china which has
quite a high level of capital controls
other countries like china argentina
iran this is where bitcoins really
caught on to a lot of people because you
just simply it's not easy to transfer
money in or out of the country without
going through regulatory problems or
having to know someone in the government
and things like that so
definitely that is a huge uh boost to
bitcoin
the advantages of bitcoin continue to
increase its popularity around the world
sometimes in the most unlikely of places
my name is david hyatt and i operate the
phoenix rising cafe in nimbun
this is where our bitcoin machine is
located right next to the traditional
atm machine
so the customers have a choice of using
either
i saw that the current banking system
was rather restrictive
and the independence of people
running their own banking systems really
appealed to me
and the fact also that it was digital
and we're living in a digital age i just
knew that it was something that would
have to get traction over time
bitcoin is
definitely the largest innovation in
monetary science since isaac newton's
gold standard
going to completely revolutionize how
all of our assets are held so it's going
to disrupt the law it's going to disrupt
accounting going to disrupt
our finance industry going to disrupt so
much
it will also
rapidly decentralize
the
capital
no longer
will
millions of people
accumulate all of their capital into one
big pile that then gets allocated by a
senior vice president of merrill lynch
or bank of america
it'll be millions of people that you
have to go and entice
out of their capital to go fight a war
in afghanistan or iraq once you
decentralize all those private keys
becomes much more difficult to get
people to pay for a lot of these goods
and services that they otherwise
wouldn't necessarily pay for
i'll just scan it
and now i have your bitcoin address in
my wallet right here and i'll go ahead
and enter one dollar
and we'll hit send mine's sending the
transaction
[Music]
sent and if you there you go you heard
the noise
before bitcoin i was basically retired i
was just hanging out enjoying my life
practicing jiu jitsu every day and it
was really fun
but wasn't really going to make the
world that much of a better place if at
all
and then i discovered bitcoin and i
looked around the world and i saw these
wars being fought and central banks
debased the currency and basically
preventing the world from being as good
of a place as it potentially could be
and i saw bitcoin and i saw this as a
tool to strip away all their power to do
that most people aren't interested in
paying to kill people they've never met
in other countries
most people are willing to pay for roads
and schools and hospitals so if the
government say we need money for roads
and schools and hospitals i think people
will probably give them a good chunk of
that if governments say we need money to
go kill people in other countries that
you've never been to in your entire life
and you're probably never going to go to
in your entire life
people are going to say no i don't want
to pay for that but with if you're using
bank accounts and dollars and euros
governments can seize all the money out
of your bank account at any time they
can print as many new dollars or euros
as they want to pay for these things at
any time if the world's using bitcoin it
takes away those tools from government
and i think that makes the world a much
much better place
for the first time in history bitcoin
now provides the entire world with a
completely decentralized payment system
one where each individual holds the
ownership and control of their own
financial wealth
one where all users can transfer value
and interact freely amongst each other
instantly
what could the future of our world look
like with such a revolutionary tool
the possibilities could be truly magical
[Music]
bitcoin is magic internet money uh
bitcoin allows you to send and receive
money with anyone anywhere in the world
just like magic there's
i'm i'm at a loss for words because it's
that exciting and that world changing
with bitcoin you can pull out your ipod
or your iphone or your tablet or
whatever install an app in less than 30
seconds you have the ability to send and
receive money with anyone anywhere in
the world basically for free and you can
be 10 years old and do that or you can
be 100 years old and do that you can do
that in any country
that's magic
[Music]
you